the makeshift memorial still stands at
the scene of the attack at berlin's cry
high blood square 12 people were killed
here last month's a shock for the entire
country but everyday life has long since
returned to the busy concourse is the
mourning period over Berliners cannot
agree they should consider up Megan I
think we've grieved enough it wasn't
news non stop by decide what should I
say you can't mourn with the bereaved
any way I see fit nirman had a feeling I
think we should have known far more we
should have made it even clearer the
attack took place and then it was in the
news and then nothing under naf varnak
smear where the public sympathy helps is
a matter for the victims loved ones to
answer in private one of the victims
came from here the town of brandenburg
west of Berlin reverent Ian's my book
has been counseling the family he says
the grief-stricken do not want any
limelight this is so dusty the families
and friends especially need more time
and we're all having to confront the
reality of an event that luckily we've
never dealt with before but which is now
a new situation that we have to learn
from dammit that's why we should be very
cautious in everything we do im sue keen
info via Sofia forest viton lassen
zoltan
public sympathy at a respectful distance
and Brandenburg they've admirably
managed this balancing act at the church
service for the victims regional
political and religious leaders took
part filming the grieving relatives were
strictly forbidden acquaintances called
at a dignified ceremony now Berlin is
also thinking about putting up some kind
of permanent memorial at the attack site
to keep memory alive while looking to
the future maximum Bo n log let's call
it maximally unimpressed it's mainly an
act of defiance against the terrorists
not a lack of sympathy or an inability
of Berliners to put themselves in others
shoes we have the self-confidence to say
you terrorists will not defeat us it was
a strong signal twist clicks ones
nishant on this one gun stalker sighting
still for many people after the attack
expressing silent sympathy and warning
was spontaneous impulse the city is
still seeking an appropriate way to
remember the attack and its victims